welcome to this video playing super
saiyajin okay never played this guy this
is a Nigerian flag right okay so let's
see what we get maybe the NIMS Oh again
okay let's play my trademark opening
here and see what we get that's very
similar to to the last game um okay very
early 5k no I don't want to do that
let's just continue developing first but
here i have a fall right this direct
attack threatening F F and F en Bishop
g5 now should provoke some sort of
reaction my black yeah like that and now
I have noisy three f5 as an idea of
course you will play Knight a5 and
everything but it's it's clear that I'm
very often sacrificing materially and
this opening let's um let's see night
see for this this Bishop is hanging
that's that's a bit bit of a problem
well I was thinking I was thinking to
take andrew keV three but that's very
doubtful this is enough compensation
okay I don't have much choice the whole
thing is based on the idea night f5 and
took g3 this kind of attack yeah that's
probably fishy hmm should be three there
should be three wasn't a good idea
because it has the bishop on e3 hanging
after the capture on c forum now this
this should should be good for black in
some way okay yeah this is weakening d6
hmm in this dangerous rock g3 here or
something like that okay so now i can at
least give this check and play on the
night bag or the check in t-5 channel
that's also also quite interesting yeah
and I don't know how but there is there
is an attack again that's it sets
dangerous Queen G 795 is downright
embarrassing so it cannot you cannot do
that so now I can never take g6 here and
takes you five
hmm yeah that is already quite quite
dangerous f5 is probably not good yeah
I'll take a check here come on let's err
is probably the most logical even if
even that even if there is a change rate
involved but it gets even more pieces
activated and Bishop before I mean this
is very close to being a checkmate there
is just f6 preventing it um okay there's
some way to make all this a bit stronger
even with the with f5 or something like
egg away 5 intending Bishop d4 check f6
and taking on g6
yeah we should be for now is Sam okay
maybe I think it is a threat it's not
easy to play him okay he's some trying
to cover the default square
especially G five as well Bishop g5 f6
their continuation after that I don't I
don't see one at the moment
maybe maybe here to threaten that
threaten Bishop g5 f6f g6 now the sir
the night on b3 it protects d4 but it's
also somewhat somewhat offside
wow that very tricky position I'd love
to have more time here to really to
really am calculate this properly now no
no I cannot believe in such luxury
luxury move here this design bodies will
not work I'm pretty sure rook h3 here o
gauge 3m night f5s is very very
dangerous to put it mildly head should
it should really win now check yeah hope
she soon made checkmate that's what's
nice that was really nice at the end i
miss played the opening but i will be
five is really a weird move I mean you
loot Lee cannot afford such a luxury
luxury move I mean maybe there was no
defense but our b5 is not working King
g7 hey with 000 evaluation funny yeah I
move like this is what what come up the
engine is giving here after I wasn't
sure if I should play f6 check on IG 494
was also interesting intending bishop
iam this is also interesting if he
captures check this rookie three made
coming so back to age 8 and this is
given as equal a better computer it
looks it looks completely bonkers with
the King car
by the pawn in the night euro made
almost yeah you're still made it here
the cook the computer line continues
like that and rook here not quite sure
maybe maybe rookie five and taking or
something as the idea there are many
ideas here to play for for mating setups
mating patterns like rookie five taking
and putting a bishop only five then then
f7 mate that's a very dangerous position
okay let's let's go back briefly maybe I
had something something better even if
I've looks looks normal yeah and this is
check just just very logical yeah
interesting here Bishop g4 is an
interesting move given us equal by the
comp and this some it wants to answer
with King g7 look D so now it looks like
like decent play yeah I think at this
let the beginning here I'm just I'm just
basically just a pawn down for fishy
compensation I have some peace activity
on the Kings side but it's not enough
but this is helping me really I believe
giving me this this nice direct attack
on the pawn count here I hear the
computer gives me a very strong
continuation roop see one rook c1 is
very strong I don't understand yet why
um
okay i can just take it uh-huh yeah i
understand the following if he retreats
let's say i take ya take and then i have
96 this is good for why they are quite
quite obviously even I this is what I
thought but I can just check check and
then that's that's just just just
terrible okay okay I didn't really look
at a truck see one okay check this
looked fairly tempting so I went for it
and d5 yeah because I saw that that my
pieces are getting opened up this this
is true but the other generation is just
much stronger this is maybe it really
isn't it's only good enough for a draw
but this is just a strong attack for
just a pawn ok good game nothing
interesting game thanks for watching